mais avant de poser ma question je
pourrais corriger une exactitude vous
n'êtes pas un collègue de ris ce risque
d'un caricaturiste vous êtes un comique
officiel vous avez un pied d'un pouvoir
un pied dans la caricature un pied à
l'elysée un pied sur canal + dans n'a
plus vraiment faim vous l'avez eu
longtemps rice non c'est la position
encore une bonne fois pour toutes vous
vous êtes un humoriste de régime bon je
vais plus dans les pays brésil a existé
dans les pays de l'est je suis humoriste
yacine avant d'avoir eu cette finition
alors j'ai justement maintenant le reste
je m'en allais mois sous mac rhône alors
n'existait pas non mais alors déjà je
peux vous répondre à de généreux dire je
suis pas ni vous avez une mission auprès
de la ville pourquoi est-ce que je peux
je vois là je ne vends pas yasi nous dit
voilà je dis juste que ce ce que je sais
c'est que yassine est proche des
banlieues et je pense que voilà c'est
pour ça voilà vous qui vous ai demandé
vous a demandé voilà de d'essayer de
voir voilà de dénis d'aidé au niveau de
la ville pour voir ce que ce qu'on
pouvait faire c'est ça je vous réponds
juste apprécié je répondrais ono alors
déjà il s'avère que le respect voudrais
de ne pas blâmer la carrière de
quelqu'un parce que vous même vous avez
participé peut-être à la montée de ma
petite carrière puisque je vous ai reçus
dans de nombreuses émissions avant même
que macro commence à faire de la
politique
une ce nombre assez suffisant pour que
vous êtes bien dans n'importe quoi en
effet désigné juste avec naulleau je
vais au bout comme ça je vous réponds
aux problèmes des vingt et un goût des
mensonges alors essayé de dire un truc
vraie âme et de temps en temps ces
jeunes je finis ma phrase je sais que
vous êtes plus habitué à voir des gens
de mon espèce vous livrer des plats des
livres ou que de vous répondre je vais
vous répondre je suis pas client chez
les libéraux d'accord très bien gilbert
p4g coup non plus alors à régater merci
je vais vous dire quelque chose
inexactitudes allez juste quelque chose
avec naulleau je sais que vous êtes
excité juste je vous dis quelque chose
vous verrez la différence et je m'excite
mais c'est un jeu fait c'est vrai c'est
lourd éric médias s'ils la désirent
je voudrais que vous fassiez une phrase
sans inexactitudes sankara canam est là
pour apprendre et très calmement tout à
l'heure j'ai c'est de démarrer vous n'y
arrivez pas à énorme dans ce que vous
racontez dans l'artois correctionnel
mans avec jimmy vous arrive pas avec moi
si je manquais regrets bien angie la
fois comme entre tout ça je vais loubeau
s'en va
je sens qu'elle admirablement avec d'une
je vais devenir avec vous mais moins
bien barré allez allez allez au colloque
c'est quand vous avez un peu d'antenne
vitrail vous êtes toute l'antenne joue à
l'aube ou juste vous préciser quelque
chose un moment je suis pas un humoriste
de régime je suis déjà revenu maurice au
régime
et deuxièmement je vais à quelque chose
voudrait dire et comment dire m'éliminer
du débat à 10 ans comme si j'étais le
bouffon du roi que je met un chapeau le
soir et que je vais voir mc ronde et là
c'est irrespectueux et c'est pas que
j'ai dit ça dans matière humoristes de
régie du régime région c'est c'est un
peu c'est le bras armé voilà de masbah
cruden bacon dans l'humour presque 6 et
voila voila four et au moulin
c'est que maintenant je n'aime pas les
recevoir du conseil et ville alors je
finis ensuite je vous dis juste quelque
chose je pense que je vous ai jamais vu
dans l'une de mes fans
dans l'un de mes spectacles je sais que
vous êtes humoriste d'accord donc à
l'orée de cette ville attendait à partir
du moment où vous n'êtes pas venu mais
pas savoir ce que je fais ce qu'ils
m'ont connu sa vie intra qui se
développe beaucoup moi j'y crois
beaucoup c'est internet
soyez attentifs vous allez voir
incroyable et je vous ai vu sur internet
si je vous ai pas vu dans une salle à je
vous jure l'émotion voudrait que si vous
venez dans une salle c'est pas comme
quand on regarde un extrait d'internet
je sais que si moi je me fiais seulement
extrait de d'internet vous concernant je
me dirai ce mec est vraiment bête donc
fait attention mais redonne chemin ils
n'ont rien a mieux lancé l'an 12 est sur
scène mais je comprends pas fait et vous
expirez andorre deux états ne va pas
avoir une opinion sur votre ex président
si elle n'y a pas de soucis vous êtes là
en train de dire il est pas collègues
jury dit je suis trois fois par semaine
en spectacle à paris au théâtre de dix
heures et il était un des ventes avant
divers
je suis un problème que les
caricaturistes qui est donné de tester
les limites de la liberté d'expression
qui est de blesser des gens et suscité
des réactions il est dans la même
commune
la raison
c'est parce que facturent à leurs
carrières et leurs entames est tendue en
entier l'a déjà je trouve que tu l'as tu
pour le coup tu peux avoir des accords
avec lui mais lui lui reprocher fin lui
enlever les sens de son métier de faire
rire et compris en provoquant des gens
tu peux pas vous l'avez écouté la radio
est aussi non bah écoutez le il n'y a
pas plus que j'ai lu élitiste vous ai
dit alors éric votre question je vais
corriger une dernière chose si je peux
pas le laisser passez votre tour votre
petite pique la sueur des libéraux
j'habite au métro couronnes vous avez
déjà regardé ardemment séparera c'est
comme me dire j'adore noir non métro
couronnes oui vous voyez un peu
l'environnement du métro couronnes en
billets que j'allais retourner pas
dessiner pour les téléspectateurs laisse
le parisien centre belleville minimes la
couronne s'il ya une très fameuse
mosquée j'habite à 50 mètres de cette
mosquée dont il m'arrive que vous a dit
m'arrive de croiser quelques arabes et
même quelques musulmans
donc ne dit pas comme moi vous les voyez
deux grands rivaux ils vont vous livrer
une pizza parce que ce que vous dites
effectivement vous dites est très con
mais vous avez commencé par regarder moi
pour mon cher peuple japonais je mange
des jeans non elle veut dire au revoir
non parce que c'est vous qui les garde
côtes japonais dans l'avenir voilà c'est
vous qui avez vous avez dit en fait vous
ne voyez des arabes quand il voue
énormément d'étudiants lors des gens
comme moi il s'avère que je vois tout le
monde mais leur moi déjà je vois à
travers vous juste le la
ils ont raconté n'importe quoi je vous
jure mais plutôt prendre un café à la
maison vous allez très surpris de rigolo
je vends bien regarder la question je
vous donne une réponse comme talent vous
avez dit franchement moi j'ai mes mots
parce que moi dans son racisme il est de
qualité
vous êtes leader price vous n'êtes même
pas bon et vous avez su même pas l'idée
que de direction s'établir à métro
couronnes etc surnommé arthur d vous
avez quoi de l'offre qui se battent en
duel à côté d'un foyer malia ça y est
vous connaissez les maliens à l'aller
c'est pas bien mais arrêtez de
condescendants 10 ans j'habite à
couronne
non mais c'est tout ne parlez pas de des
libéraux des trucs comme ça c'est pas de
votre niveau même vous vous êtes au
dessus de ça c'est dire là il s'avère de
moins ma femme ne fait pas manger je
commence souvent des libéraux et j'ai
pas de problème avec alors eric je
voudrais demander à monsieur biya terme
en fait il a pas l'air très en forme ce
soir je regardais le meilleur sur scène
s'il est prêt à s'excuser et s'il est
prêt à retirer un tweet ignoble ouais il
a posté à l'intention de zineb el
rhazoui
une saisine et charrier maillot qu'il a
quitté depuis 2010 est et qui provoque
assez régulièrement des polémiques dont
je me fais l'écho sur d'autres plateaux
notamment à touche pas à mon poste
exactement puisqu'elle avait elle series
elle avait notamment clamé et ailleurs
mais ici on en avait parlé il faut tirer
à balles réelles dans les banlieues donc
ça et provoqué un énorme tollé
et c'est vrai que elle aussi on le dit
elle a une certaine immunité auprès des
bien pensants je le dis voilà il faut
dire la vérité on peut par escrocs la
pratique et puisque ben wallace est une
rescapée de charlie hebdo ont dit la
vérité donc presque intérieur
elle était passée voilà c'est une
enseigne de charlie hebdo et voilà donc
elle est extrêmement elles apprennent
extrêmement beaucoup de sécurité autour
d'elle elle est extrêmement menacée mais
c'est vrai qu'elle jouit d'une certaine
immunité et on le comprend on peut
comprendre voilà auprès de la presse
bien pensante dès qu'on s'attaque un peu
asie n'est brazza oui on le paie très
cher on a on le paye très cher et tout
le monde vous tombe dessus et c'est bien
ça le reste voilà exactement oui c'est
que mathieu béda scolaire j'avais dit
moi aussi que c'était inadmissible
khalidi feu tiré à balles réelles en
second lieu que moi aussi je trouverai
une amie soit là c'est inadmissible
c'est d'aller vous allez provoquer c'est
ni bon pour la police parce que voilà
ces libyens pour la police ni bien pour
les banques d'accord avec vous donc
voilà si on revenait de temps là-dessus
après il avait donc je dirai simplement
savoir si vous êtes prêts alors on va
reprendre la nouvelle année gillet ben
el rhazoui el rhazoui avait dit que là
dès 2020 soit celle de la victoire sur
le fascisme islamique et que la france
soit le pays où il sera terrasse et
bonne année
happy new year donc on voit qu'elle est
bilingue et yassine belattar
éliminatoires a répondu inch'allah tu es
plus là en 2020 alors ma question est la
suivante est ce que vous trouvez
pertinents intelligente responsable
d'associer la religion musulmane à
travers l'expression inch allah est une
menace de mort étant donné les amalgames
il a fait toute la journée entre
justement l'islam et le terrorisme
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est le
truc le plus intelligent que vous ayez
fait parce que vous êtes prêt à vous en
excusé et a retiré ce tweet le jeu lui
persiste à qualifier de laisser mon père
c'est mon père
voilà il faut sorte la poubelle non
peut-être aussi lorsque je fais c'est
que je twitte et avant twitté je vous
l'envoie croix verte on est ok croix
pendant la grève
alors alors
la réponse de yacine dans un instant on
se retrouve dans un instant pour la si
je demandais à monsieur blatter s'il
trouvait pertimm en pertinent
intelligents et responsables d'associer
la relation la religion musulmane avec
l'expression inch allah
un désir de mort envers sydney ben el
rhazoui puisque voilà son mail
inch'allah en 2020 et plus alors il
s'avère que je vais dire une chaleur
2020 2021
jusqu'à mon dernier souffle je dirais
une charles lacoste s'est ensuite moins
une classe à me va très bien
oui oui il ya même une chanson mais qui
s'appelle inchallah il ne la chantaient
pas à l'ayroule atterré par la suite des
paroles je vais vous dire quelque chose
moins tenable je les aime beaucoup c'est
ma cousine du bled qui est zineb el
rhazoui comme ça les gens comprennent
c'est quelqu'un qui pendant longtemps
c'est réclamer des attentats de charlie
hebdo alors que eux ne faisait pas
partie et je remercie rice d'avoir
totalement des masques et zineb el
rhazoui puisqu'elle était sous une
procédure de licenciement
donc ça veut dire que l'on était
quasiment en train de quitter charlier
il s'avère que cette dame depuis
quelques temps à trouver sa place sur
les plateaux télé parce que tous les ans
il ya une nouvelle mode
vous avez été une mode vous êtes un peu
dépassée mais il ya eu ces mots
renolleau après il ya eu la gauche
laïcarde c'est à dire c'est des gens ils
sont de gauche mais il n'aime pas
beaucoup les musulmans dorénavant il ya
ce phénomène très cool qui s'appelle les
ex musulman donc je savais pas qu'on
pouvait être musulman mais tant mieux et
elle s'est pas limité je regrette
zemmour c'est à dire que l ce qu'elle
dit sur l'islam c'est même plus
bienveillants c'est à dire qu'elles vont
nourrir
alors ça c'est naulleau qui le dit et je
pense faut saisir le faut il le dire
était plus à ce que ce député plus en
france ou est ce que c'est juste une
charlaté plus en 2020 dans l'espace
médiatique et ça d'accord comme ça que
c'est interprété moi ça m'est arrivé pas
interprété par un vous le savez arrêtez
de toujours qu'ils se prennent très bien
tout le monde
mieux les pamina juste je voudrais tracy
la dame rose bonbon je finis juste avec
lui non parce que je me souviens plus de
son nom je me suis dit ça y est nous
plus là je voudrais tellement médiocres
n'ont point faible opinion de vous mais
alors là avec cette première remarque
dur et je voulais c'est un petit espace
en me disant peut-être que c'est un mec
à peu près structurée mais vous êtes en
plus à un espèce de mode chaud méprisant
pour les faits il avait clôturé votre
profil à lorient mais je m'en fous pas
d'avis de prédateurs sans le vote qui
m'intéressent assurez vous de lui
déjà je vais vous dire tout ce qui peut
penser chacun peut venir me parler oui
je suis une femme excusez moi en rose
mais je peux parler quand même à nier ce
que je vais dire doubler en franche
comté en appelle donc je vais vous dire
quelque chose mais je finirai portable
je finis avec nous l'avons entamée la
veille en terre sur ce que vous faites
depuis le début vous clivé c'est à dire
si les livres des livres ou
obligatoirement c'est des musulmans les
musulmans tous les musulmans ou parlons
nous tous les musulmans n'ont pas pu se
retrouver dans les commémorations mais
il ya plein de musulmans qui étaient
dans les commémorations il y avait plein
de musulmans qui ne pratiquent pas vous
ne parlez pas au nom des musulmans et
heureusement pour eux d'ailleurs parce
que la majorité des musulmans ne sont
pas comme vous dans un combat politique
que vous menez en permanence voyez c'est
ça la différence
il ya laissé les musulmans tranquille
exercer leur culte tranquille et ou
payer les emmerdes personnes alors que
vous vous êtes dans un combat politique
dit le sous couvert d'humour
c'est ça la différence assumer bien sûr
que vous êtes dans un combat politique
d'ailleurs vous avez je vais faire ma
question tout de suite comme ça à
l'extérieur rien ce domaine bol de
toutes les nations des bonbons non non
mais alors déjà naulleau vous posez
votre question mais quand vous avez tort
d'être délaissé leur il vous répondra
après eric près je vous réponds là les
états
vous aurez des bonbons roses y'a pas de
soucis l'ont plutôt bon goût et eric
juste pour vous répondre
- anabel rhazoui elle peut dire ce
qu'elle veut
je pense puisque vous l'avez analysé ici
oui oui je vous le dis ici si quelque
chose me dit pas non c'est le respect
voudrait que si je le dis c'est que je
l'assumé si je le dis
la fiche non j'ai pas le droit de parler
ses 600 blessés lors effet dialogue et
cnpc le répondre aux questions gérer ça
au lot un quart d'heure pour préparer
une réponse arrête tout de suite si vous
avez vous parlé sur yacine on arrête
tout de suite vous laisse y répondre
mais c'est en ces tristes parce que
franchement je veux bien suivi et les
plâtres mais c'est normal message clair
aux invités laissez les invités
répondent en parle mal français
couramment c'est génial je vous dit
quelque chose
vous avez vu tout à l'heure et une
coupure pub juste avant il ya un moment
intéressant dans le public quand ils ont
lu le tweet bas il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont rigolé oui bon moi je pars du
principe que quand c'est écrit comme ça
vous pouvez faire dire n'importe quoi à
mon tweet alors il s'avère que dans la
bible écrit les paroles s'envolent les
écrits restent
à partir du moment où il ya eu un trouve
rigolo derrière ce qui est mon métier un
humoriste croyez moi je n'ai aucune
ambition de faire le quoi que ce soit
zineb el rhazoui je trouve que ce
qu'elle dit sur les plateaux télé et je
rejoins la position de cyril est
extrêmement grave selon moi elle n'a pas
le totem charlie elle décide de prendre
des positions sur des gens pardon vous
dire ça c'est souvent lui même et dire
des choses qui sont du domaine quasiment
de l'inadmissible parce que il ya tiré à
balles réelles
mais quand vous dites je me dis que je
suis pas d'accord je vais au bout moi
j'ai le droit aujourd'hui puisque vous
êtes duellistes s'ils savaient que je
lui une fois une de vos épargnes qui est
intéressant vous aimez le duel c'est
vrai moi aussi j'aime bien le duo genève
elle décide quand elle est en duel ou
pas - il s'avère que je ne veux pas me
retrouver sur un plateau télé avec elle
que souvent elles retweet des trucs vous
êtes sur twitter
j'avoue que des fois ça me fait rire
vous twittez des trucs vous mentez vous
manger des chips storm avec des gens qui
écrivent des trucs inadmissible sur vous
c'est le jeu de twitter en attendant je
me dis juste quelque chose ne fait pas
dire à ma phrase quelque chose qui
laisserait croire que je vais aller à
dame a martelé je n'écoute jamais
eric naulleau si yacine faux lui répond
eric naulleau vous dit ça ça aussi alors
là je vous le dis tout yade a qui ont
compris le second degré y en a
énormément comprennent zaouahri de
inch'allah c'est devenu une vanne voilà
in salah et plus de 2000 ans et pas une
seule un qui me dérange si c'est leur
job et oui mais l'autre on voit très
bien le ton c'est plus tes pleurs de
bien moi je l'avais plus pris je vous
dis la vérité
comme tu es plus dans l'espace
médiatique on en entend plus en 2020 on
dit j'ai pas pris ça j'espère qu'en 2020
je vais youtube à disparaître
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu twitté de
charles en 2020 il ya un temps qui tu
roules dessus et on crie allah ouakbar
là vous dites vous de chrome os qui se
dit bon ben là c'est pas drôle là jaurès
a pas de défendre et juste chose en plus
pour finir nos l'atome l'annoncera
j'aime pas cette idée ont exulté vous
arrange bien quoi l'ambiguïté vous avons
jamais lui il est génial parce que vous
arrivez au disque et puis les cds sont
apparaît comme dana s'il vous plaît
n'oubliez pas que yassine belattar mine
de rien je le redis yacine c'est un
humoriste donc écolo c'est bien de le
rappeler parce que on a tendance à
l'oublier
ah non il ya les gens qui viennent voir
le spectacle en général se rappelle bien
quand je monte sur scène que je suis
plutôt quelqu'un de drôle mais je
comprends pas le truc naulleau vraiment
c'est une question vous n'acceptez pas
l'idée que je sois humoriste chez
d'accord donc j'ai défini comme une
catégorie précise d'humoristes bord
baisse de régime depuis le bouffon du
roi ça n'existe pas moi je veux bien que
dans quand vous venez en vélo vous
répéter votre punch lines mais il faut
qu'elle s'avère qu'elle soit vraie
toujours pas de vélo moi je ne suis pas
dans le pouvoir
d'accord je ne je ne faisais pas je ne
je ne fais pas de politique je suis pas
engagé politiquement
nominé il s'avère que je vous jure on
peut s'appeler yassine belattar et avoir
une vision pour son pays en 2020 alors
peut-être que monsieur politique
prédécesseur avait toujours quelque 150
g dans lotus à papier dont l'humour qui
est dans la menace un pied dans le
pouvoir un pied dans l'humour trop
facile alors s'il vous plaît c'est assez
dur pour vous mais c'est pas facile pour
les autres caisses et je vous le dire